بعد فشل البسيج جيران تنقل مليشياتها من
العراق وسوريا للمشاركه في قمع الاحتجاجات
ردا على
اعتراضها بالدفاع عن الاوكراني
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
الاشرطه لاهم الانباء من العربي
ون رسميا معركه طهران للقضاء على
الاحتجاجات اوله دفعات المقاتلين وصلت
طهران بالفعل وبحسب وسائل الاعلام ايرانيه
فان اللجوء النظام الى ميليشياته يعود
لتردد قوات الامن وعجزها عن قمعين
وبحسب المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان فانه
عناصر من الميليشيات الموليه لايران بداوا
الانتقال الى طهران وكان تقرير سابق
لايران انترناشونال افاده ان حزب الله
اللبناني نشر قوته في طهران
لمساعدته
من الحشد الشعبي العراقي
ومقاتلي كتائب حزب الله
في رحله مباشره من بغداد الى مشهد في شمال
شرق ايران
تقرير ايران للسند الى وثائق سريه من هو
واحده تشير الى ان حزب الله سينشر 4000
مقاتل في ايران
مع وزير الخارجيه البريطاني الاوضاع في
اوكرانيا والدعم المقدم بالاضافه الى
الاعدامات وانتهاكات حقوق الانسان في
ايران من جهته قال وزير الخارجيه
البريطاني جيمس كليفر ان دعم ايران
للجماعات الارهابيه ادى الى اراقه الدماء
في المنطقه معتبرون ان البرنامج النوويه
الايراني تهديد للامن الدوري مؤكدا دعم
بلاده لما طالب الايرانيين في مواجهه
القمر
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسنال فوندر
لاين انها تؤيد ادراج الحرس الثوري
الايراني على قائمه المنظمات
وهم يدرسون على حقوق الانسان الاساسيه
باقدمهم لذا فانما نراه امر لا يصدق وما
يحدث في ايران يحتاج الى رساله قويه جدا
ورد فعل قوي جدا بالتالي فاننا نتطلع
بالفعل الى جوله جديده من العقوبات وساؤيد
ايضا ادراج الحرس الثوري في القائمه لقد
سمعت عده وزراء يطلبون ذلك واعتقد انهم
على حق
عندما كان يشغل منصب المدعي العام في
ايران كان رئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيس عضو
في لجنه الموت التي اشرفت على اعدامي مئات
السجناء السياسيين في طهران وفقا لما
نقلته رويترز عن منظمات حقوقيه اليوم وبعد
حوالي ثلاثه عقود اصبح رئيسا للبلاد ولا
زال يشرف على قمر الايرانيين قد تم توثيقه
قرابه ال 500
الايراني في ماده السجناء السياسيين عام
من وزاره الاستخبارات ل بصير يا لافي
المعتقلين في محاكمات تعسفيه
استغرقت دقائق فقط وفقا لتقرير نشراته
منظمه العفو الدولي
تزداد تقديرات في اسرائيل بان اللجوء الى
عمل العسكري ضد المنشات النوويه في ايران
اصبح اكثر واقعيه هذا العام رغم تاكيد
مصادر رمليه اسرائيليه مطلعه ان العمليه
العسكريه ضد طهران ليست جاهزه بعد لكن
الجيش
اوامر المستوى السياسي
مشهد رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي وهو يجلس
صعوبه في تغريد رئيس الاركان الجديد رتبته
العسكريه ويضعها مقلوبه قد تكون مصادفه
لكنها لم تخلو من مفارقه رمزيه فالجينرال
هيرسياليفي ليس خيار تنياه المفضل لانه من
تعيينه وزير الدفاع السابق غانس في اخر
ايام الحكومه الانتقاليه في مع اراد
نتنياهو مستشاره العسكري السابق اللواء
يلتمر
الاصطدام بين الرئيس الاركان الجديد
حول الملف الايراني يبدو ضئيلا ربما
مستبعدا هناك اجماع بين المستويين السياسي
والعسكري حول الملف الايراني
ايضا انه على الرغم من ان نتنياهو ليس
مغامرا عسكريا عاده يرى نفسه من منظور
تاريخيه كما سينهي المشروع النوي الايراني
ويستهدف المنشات ويستذكرون عام واثنى عشر
حين قرر ذلك فعليا لكنه معارضه رئيس
الاركان في حينه بنجانس والمؤسسه الامنيه
منعت التنفيذ لهذا قد لا يكون مرتاحا
لوجود هاليفي الذي عينه
[موسيقى]
غازنا الجيش والمصاد بالتعاون مع جهاز
الشباك سيقومون بما يلزم للرد بحرب ضد
اعدائنا نظام ايران مسؤول عن 90% من مشاكل
المنطقه ويهدد بتدميرنا الاعتقاد في
اسرائيل لم يتغير بان ايران تستطيع خلال
اسابيع الانطلاق الى تقسيمه يورانيوم
بنسبه 90% اللازمه لانتاج قنبله نوويه لكن
التطوير الراس الحربي والتسليح يحتاج اقل
من عامين ويبقى السؤال امام قائد جيشها
الجديد متى يشن هجوم عسكريه على ارضيه
التخصيب ام عند المرحله النهائيه قبل
التسليح التهديداته والتدريبات
الاسرائيليه العالم بتوع على توجيه ضربه
لايران وفق مراقبين قد تحتمل تفسيرين
متناقضين فقد تكون لتهيئه راي عاميه لضربه
اسرائيليه مستقله للمنشات او العكس اي
محاوله ترجع ايران عن الهروله تجاه
القنبله النوويه منعا لهجوم اسرائيلي غير
جاهز بعد زياد حلبي العربيه القدس الغربيه
وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه جيمس كليفر لي
دعم بلاده للوكرانيين
على تسليم دبابات بريطانيه لاوكرانيا
بان الرساله التي نرسلها الى الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين هي اننا ملتزمون
بالدفاع عن الاوكرانيين حتى يحققوا النصر
هذا وكاله لندن قد اعلنت قبل ايام انها
ستسلم وكيف دبابات
اول بلد يسلم كيف دبابات ثقيله غربي
الى ذلك وصلت هنا طائرات المراقبه التابعه
لحلف الناتو الى قاعده جويه بالقرب من
العاصمه الرومانيه بوخارست حيث من المقرر
ان تكون الطائرات بمهامه استطلاعيه
اقليميه لمراقبه النشاط العسكريه الروسي
داخل اراضي التحالف العسكري كما انه من
المتوقع ايضا ان تصل طائرتان مراقبه
اخريان الى العاصمه الرومانيه تقوم
بمهامها خلال الاسابيع المقبله
البيت الابيض
سياسيه اعتبره وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
الاسبق هنري كيسنجر ان الغزو الروسي
لاوكرانيا اظهر انه لم يعد هناك من مبرر
لبقايا كيف خارج خلفي شمال الاطلسي رغم
انه كان في السابق من المعارضين لهذه
الخطوه كاس الجول قال انها فكره اوكرانيا
المحايده في ظل هذه الظروف لم تعد تجدوه
بينما شدت الولايات المتحده على ان القرار
بشان الانضمام الى حلف شمال الاطلسي يعود
الى اوكرانيا لم تبدي القوى الاوروبيه اي
حماسه بسبب القلق من الحيض عمارات الامن
المتبادله لدوله تشهد نزاعا مع روسيا منذ
العام 2014
لفت مفوضه حقوق الانسان الروسيه تتيانا
مشكل كوفا اجراء محادثات مع نظيرها
الاوكراني في تركيا الاسبوع الماضي حول
تبادل المحتمل للاسرار الجانب التركي كان
نقل لروسيا قائمه من 800 شخص قدمته
اوكرانيا
من جهتها او موسكو قدمت من جهتها قائمه
تضم 200
تبادلهم اعتبرتهم
ان قضايا الاسرى وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
معتبره ان هذا التبادل غير متكافل وغيره
ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد الفاصل
المحكمه العليا الامريكيه تبدا النظر في
قضيه انتياكه بنك خلق التركي للعقوبات على
ايران
اهلا بكم من جديد
الى ترامب في مقر الولايه حيث يكشف عن
طريق قياده حملته في الولايه وهما سيراتو
متصل قال الرئيس الامريكي السابق ترامب
بانه سيتعامل مع ترشحين لرئاسه اذا تحدث
حاكم فلوريدا ترشيح الحزب الجمهوري لرئاسه
لعام 20 24
الوحيد الذي اعلن عن ترشيحه للانتخابات
حتى الان واجه انخفاضا في دعم الاساسي
وقال الناخبون انهم يفضلون
24 24
اكيد البيت الابيض انه سيتعاون مع التحقيق
بشير وثائق بايدينا سريه بنيه الحسنه
مشيرا الى انه سيردوا على استفسارات
الوارده من لجنه الرقابه بمجلس النواب
بشان تخزين غير سليم للوثائق السريه في
منزل الرئيس الامريكي بيان البيت الابيض
اضاف ان كشف تفاصيل التحقيقات يضر بالقضيب
معتبرا ان الجمهوريين
يستغلون قضيه الوثائق في مسرحيه
تنظروا المحكمه العليا
بنك خلق التركي حيث
بانتهاك العقوبات التي فرضتها واشرطه على
ايران
المحكمه الى ملكيه انه بصفته بصفا مبلوكا
من الدوله
بالمشاركه في مخطط استمر مده عام لغسل
مليارات الدولارات للبيع نفط الايراني
مصاري التطبيعه بين سوريا وتركيا خلال
الزياره وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه حسين
امير عبد الله يعني الى تركيا حيث 9 طهاره
حسب مراقبين الى الدخول على خط الوسط بين
تركيا والنظام السوري
على موقع الخطوات التركيه نحو التطبيع مع
دمشق وصل وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين
امير عبد اللهيان الى انقره للبحث عن موطئ
قدم لبلاده في مسار التطبيع الجديد
التصريحات الرسميه بين مسؤول البلدين لم
تخرج عن مالوف الدبلوماسيه من ترحيب
بالجهود السياعيه لتقريب وجوهات النظر بين
تركيا والنظام السوري
نتائج واضحه سنكون على تواصل مع ايران
وتغير شكل العلاقات بين الدولتين نحن
ممتنون جدا من وصول العلاقات الى هذا
المستوى ندعم ونؤمن باي خطوه ايجابيه بين
الدولتين
خفايا الاجتماعات وفقه ما نقلت مصادر من
انقره ابرزت رغبه ايرانيه في دور محوريه
بالوساطه بين الاتراك ونظام الاسد موازن
للدوري الروسي وذلك قبل توجه وزير
الخارجيه التركي الى واشنطن لنقل هذا
الملف الى طاوله المسؤولين الامريكيين
الرافدين للتقارب مع الاسد لكن دوره طهران
المنشود يراه اخرون انه بعيد المنال حاليا
امام وساطه روسيه قويه نجحت في عقد لقاء
ثلاثي على مستوى وزراء الدفاع
للحوار التركي السوري ولكن هناك دور روسي
ابراس وهناك وساطه روسيه همم
تحقيق هذا الاجتماع الوزاري بالبساطه
الروسيه وفي موسكو ويسود اعتقاده الاوساط
السياسيه التركيه
ان طهران لعبت دورا في تاخير اجتماع وزراء
خارجيه تركيا وروسيا وسوريا حيث كان من
المنتظر ان يعقد في النصف الثاني من يناير
الجاري لكن الاجتماع تاجل ولم تسرع عجله
التطبيع وفق الاهواء التركيه يرى متابعون
لمسار التطبيع مع دمشق ان انقره ستحاول
على الاقل خلال الفتره الحاليه تجنب
الاستعانه بواسطه جديد طالما ان الوساطه
الروسيه ما زالت تؤتي ثمارها وتقبل تركيا
لدور ايراني لن يكون الا في حال تعثرت
موسكو بالوصول الى اختراقات تمنح انقره
مكاسب سريعه قبل الانتخابات زيدان زينجو
العربيه اسطنبول
وكما تشاهدون على شاشه العربيه
تمت اضافه ماده البرلمان والعراقي الجديد
وسط خلافات تعصف بكل من البيت السياسي
الشيعي والسني والكردي حول عده ملفات على
راسها الموازنه واللجان النيابيه وصولا
الى الدرجات الخاصه قوى الاطار التنسيقي
تتنافس بشراسه للظفر برئاسه اللجان
النيابيه الامر الذي ادى الى عدم حسمها
حتى الان
مساله خلافات
القوى السنيه هي الاخرى لم تكن بعيده عن
الخلافات حول بعض القضايا التي تتعلق
بالموازنه وتمثيلها داخل الحكومه داخل
تحالف عزم اضافه الى استقاله احد النواب
عن حزب تقدم لكنها لم تصل الى حدوث
انشقاقات كبيره داخل الحزب كما روجت بعض
القوى المنويه للحلبوسي
في وجود انشقاقات او انقسامات داخل البيت
السني بعيده في الوقت الراهن حتى ان حزب
التقدم الى الان لا زال متماسكا نعم قد
يكون هناك انشقاق نائب او او اكثر هذا لا
يؤثر على تماسك حزب التقدم البيت السياسي
الكردي رغم خلافته الداخليه بين اربيل
وسليمانيه الا انه ما يفاوضان بغداد بوفد
مشترك حول حصه اقليم كردستان في الموازنه
الاتحاديه العديده
بالتوازن السياسي الانتخابات النيابيه في
الاقليم وانتهاء بكيفيه الشراكه السياسيه
وايضا العلاقه مع بغداد نوعيه العلاقه ام
بغداد تمثيل اقليم كروسان في اندوستورين
مع بعض جميع هذا النقاط الخلافه لم تحل
هذا اللحظات
السياسيه التي ادت الى تشكيل حكومه
السوداني لم تفلح في تدليل الخلافات بين
القوى المؤقعه عليها والتي تمثلت بعجزها
عن تجاوز خلافاتها حول موازنه 2023 من
بغداد منتظر رشيد العربيه
في تونس تدخل الحمله الانتخابيه
للانتخابات التشريعيه يومها الثاني
لا رجوع الى الورق
في المركز الاعلامي للانتخابات انطلقت
عمليه التحضير للدور الثاني من تشريعيات
المبكره التي ستدور نهايه الشهر الحالي
هيئه الانتخابات تعلن انها على اتم
الاستعداد لانجاح هذا الاستحقاق رغم كل
التعطيلات
مع دور ثاني
اقل المترشحين اقل ويكون فمه تنافس
الرئيس سعيد يؤكد مره اخرى انه لا مجال
للعوده الى الوراء ويصدر مرسوم لدعوه
الناخبين للتوجه الى صناديق الاقتراع امر
اربك قيادات النهضه التي فشلت مره اخرى
بدورها في تحريك الشارع قطار 25 مواصل
والخارطه السياسيه مواصله للدور الثاني في
الانتخابات التشري التشريعيه وده يعني هو
مسار 25 جولي هو اللي امسح يعني منظومه
الزمن والانتخابي يوازيه اخر قضائيه
في النهضه بتهمه تدليس جوازات سفر تونسيه
وتسليمها لعناصر ارهابيه قضيه اخرى من
القضايا المتورطه فيها قيادات النهضه
تنضاف الى قضايا الفساد والاغتيالات
والارهاب وتبييض الاموال
الماكينه التي صنعتها حركه النهضه داخل
المؤسسات التي تحاول ان تعطل اليوم ما
يربها هي ان هذه القدره على حمايه وتخطيط
كل هذه القضايا انتهت وبالتالي اصبح
مكشوفين ما يرعبهم هو كشف الحقائق
وسيتم تركيزه البرلمان الجديد بدايه شهر
مارس اغار المقبل ومن اؤكد اولوياته النظر
في قانون تمويل الاحزاب والجمعيات لا شيء
يوقفوا قتال تغيير المشهد السياسيه
التونسي واستكمال مشروع الرئيس سعيد عبر
تركيزه البرلمان الجديد واغلاق فتره حكم
الاخوان الذين صاروا يواجهون اسوء زوبعه
قضائيه وسياسيه عصفت بوجودهم في البلاد
مراقبهم وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس
اعفاء رئيس البرازيلي اليوس ايناسيو لادول
سيلفا 40 من العسكريين العاملين في القصر
السياسي بعد تعهد اجراء مراجعه شامله
للطاقه من الامن
شغب التي شهدت العاصمه البرازيليه في
الثامن من يناير الجاري
والكونجرس والمحكمه العليا
توفيق مساعدته تيار الرحله المنكوبه التي
تحطمت في نيبال الاحد الماضي لتلحق بزوجها
الذي توفي في حادث تحطم طائره مشابه قبل
16 عاما وكانت انجو خاتم تشارك في قياده
الطائره التي سقطت بالقرب من مدينه بخارى
ما اسفر عن مقتل جميع من كانوا علمتها في
اسوان كارثه جويه
عامه
لذات الخطوط الجويه وكانت وفاته هي الدافع
وراء عملها في مجال الطيران
احتفالات قريه اسبانيا بمهرجان الرس
لومينارياس السنوي المعني بتنقيه الخيول
وحمايتها من الامراض خلال العام التالي
بحسب التقاليد وذلك عبر سيرهم مع كلا
بركبهم ليلا ببطء وسط حرائق حدها سوكان
القريه
[تصفيق]
بعد فشل البسيج ايران تنقل ميليشيات من
العراق وسوريا للمشاركه في قمع الاحتجاجات
ردا على اعتراض بالدبابات
الشهر
دائما المزيد على شاشه العربيه نلقاكم بعد
قليل فالقاء
[موسيقى]